عندما يتعلق الامر باختيار الطعام عليك
الاخذ ببعض النصائح اولا يجب تجنب الدهون
المشبعه التي تتواجد في اللحوم الدسمه
والاطعمه التي تحتوي على زيت النخيل او
زيت جوز الهند اننا ناكل العديد من
الاطعمه التي تحتوي على الدهون المشبعه
حيث تتسبب لنا بعد ذلك في بدايه تصلب
الشرايين وتضيق الاوعيه الدمويه يزيد من
خطر الاصابه بالازمات القلبيه والسكته
الدماغيه الثاني هو تحاش الدهون غير
المشبعه انها السم بعينه وتثير الدهون غير
المشبعه الكولسترول المضره في الجسم وتوجد
في بعض انواع السمن النباتي والمخبوزات
مثل الكعك
والبسكويت تجنب السكريات وزياده العصائر
والحبوب غير الكامله 100% وذلك لانها
تتسبب باحداث طفرات غير صحيه وارتفاع
بمعدل السكري في الدم بالتالي تزيد من
نسبه الاصابه بمرض السكري يجب انلا يزيد
مستوى السكر عن 4 رامات في الساعه او
حوالي ثلث ملعقه
صغيره y